nous sommes en quelque sorte en route
vers la coupe du monde commence la
semaine prochaine et ce sera les matchs
seront comme vous savez présentée à
radio-canada
depuis quelques jours nous allons à la
rencontre aussi de jeunes passionnés à
huit équipes qui se font entre eux un
concours sur facebook on vous donnera
l'adresse pendant le reportage
il ya quelques jours soir je suis allé
assister à un entraînement d'une de ses
équipes de parc extension du club
panellinios impressionnant la qualité
est une cerise ont 15 ans sont dans le 3
à pipe pas compliqué sont presque au
meilleur que certains joueurs de
l'impact
c'est une blague vous allez voir très
impressionnant je vous présente balle ou
wesley est le papa de wesley qui est
l'entraîneur luis
parce que montréal est devenue une bonne
de sac
oui ça monte de plus en plus le niveau
augmente depuis la ligue 3 à l'académie
des packs le niveau et comment
s'appelait augmenté toi ton rêve si tu
te rendes jusqu'où ou tu veux jouer je
joue pour l'équipe nationale du portugal
mais ça serait un bon début mais
j'aimerais bien jouer plus haut niveau
en europe tout aussi tu vises très haut
là le plus possible c'est à dire des
équipes à l'europe comme le real madrid
ou même si si j'ai le choix je vois ici
frais j'ai mal choisi ici quelle est la
voie à suivre dans les prochaines années
si vous voulez effectivement si votre
fils et balou veulent aller
professionnels si l'académie à montréal
on est équipé pour entraîner oui de plus
en plus l'équipement est incroyable les
terrains il devient de plus en plus
bonnes conditions la ville je pense
qu'il y ait depuis un couple d'années on
voit la différence dans tous les parcs
ça s'améliore à chaque année le niveau
sa mère incroyablement d'ailleurs on a
eu des joueurs qui font partie de
l'équipe du québec captée par la semaine
prochaine pour rien car l'équipe
nationale donc on est vraiment fiers
d'eux autres puis on continue à
travailler fort et là c'est la coupe du
monde qui commence est ce que vous avez
vous préféré
est-ce que vous avez vos équipes votre
équipe
moi je suis la côte d'ivoire ivoirienne
2 pour 1 contre et une possession de
balle par mois dès vos coéquipiers ce
qui est fascinant c'est que ça vient de
toutes les origines
c'est vraiment le montréal comme on les
aime aussi
ouais on est déjà de partout n'importe
quelle origine
il est pas une comme on est amis on est
tout proche puis on est très bien jouer
sur terrain on se communique bien on
arrive à bien jouer des bons résultats
vous avez le temps quand même - bâle où
on est dans la même classe le matin de 8
heures 10 à 12h vin on à l'école puis
après on parle sport études à laval puis
on pratique jusqu'à 5 heures vous êtes
paré toutes les deux ça fonctionne bien
les notes sont là les matières ça va
bien
et est ce que là ils sont plus sévères
parce qu'on est là avec la caméra ou ou
ton papa il vous ne vous lâche pas
normalement il nous faut plus
non mais c'est bien parce que c'est rare
des coachs comme ça qui nous lient nos
deux fois ils ont tamponné zay et pour
être serré donc c'est ça qui n'ont
qu'une petite qui nous booste le plus
possible pour à nous améliorer
la meilleure des chances que vous
travaillez fort pour ça merci à cerveau
m